le luxembourg aimable petit état
d'environ 2500 kilomètres carrés est un
vrai paradis fiscal
des milliers de milliards d'euros ils
sont placés dans le cadre de sociétés
offshore
voilà ce qu'a révélé une enquête d'un an
du journal le monde
et de seize médias internationaux place
à open luxe une base de données inédites
constitué par le monde révèlent que plus
de 6500 milliards d'euros sont stockés
dans des sociétés off shore au
luxembourg sur la liste des
propriétaires figurent des milliardaires
des artistes des sportifs des criminels
cette fois ci les enquêteurs n'ont pas
eu besoin de fuite ils ont simplement
épluché 3,3 millions de documents rendus
publics par une directive européenne de
2018 et leur découverte révèle l'ampleur
de cette optimisation fiscale sur les
140 mille sociétés immatriculées active
90% sont détenus par des non résidents
55000 compagnies offshore coquille vide
sans employer son bureau ont été créées
par des fortunes on retrouve des noms
comme cristiano ronaldo ou encore le roi
du bahreïn des centaines de
multinationales comme lvmh altis pfizer
amazon ils placent secrètement leur
profit les mafias et régimes corrompus
du monde entier ils y ont également
trouvé refuge
la liste des actifs donnent le tournis
des yo des hélicoptères le vignoble
d'angelina jolie et brad pitt
une des surprises du dossier réside dans
la quantité de fortunes françaises
impliquées on y trouve 37 des 50
familles hexagonal les plus fortunés
tels les mulliez les guerrand hermès ou
bernard arnault quinze mille français
dont la plupart ne réside pas au
luxembourg ils détiennent 100 milliards
d'euros d'actifs en comparaison les
recettes de l'état pour 2020 ont atteint
250 milliards
cet argent est en grande majorité
réinvesti dans d'autres entreprises
mais bien entendu avec une fiscalité
avantageuse des cas de fraude fiscale
ont aussi été repérés par les
journalistes
une enquête révèle aussi que le
luxembourg a mis fin à ces dispositifs
fiscaux les plus avantageux pour les
multinationales depuis le scandale des
loques 6 mai restent un lieu privilégié
d'investissement et ce grâce à la
politique mise en place par un de ses
anciens premiers ministres qui n'est pas
tout à fait un inconnu
jean claude juncker l'ancien président
de la commission européenne et le
luxembourg a réagi très vite le 7
février en rejetant les a
mation contenues dans cette série
d'articles un peu trop vite même car ils
n'avaient pas encore été publiés
des ong des politiques français se sont
indignés en prenant connaissance de
cette enquête
écoeurés par l' indécence fiscale qui
règne encore en europe malgré les
scandales à répétition certes c'est la
transparence imposée par lieu qui a
permis les révélations open luxe mais ça
ne suffit pas il faut réguler il faut un
taux minimum européen
pendant que les jeunes font la queue
pour la soupe populaire une poignée de
malfrats fraude l'impôt et la solidarité
nationale le luxembourg s'est pas loin
douaniers inspecteurs du fisc pourrait
même y aller en train
d'aucuns se sont étonnés que le
gouvernement largement relayée par les
médias et dénoncé la fraude sociale dont
le montant atteint 1 milliard d'euros en
tout mais ils n'ont pas été très bruyant
quant à l'ampleur de cette évasion ou
nouvelle fraude fiscale française de 100
milliards la taxation d'une infime
portion de cette manne pour être un bol
d'air pour le service public
et puisque l'on parle de chiffres le
ministère de la justice est doté d'un
budget de 8,2 milliards ce qui lui
permettrait de lutter plus efficacement
contre ce fléau
mais quels sont les derniers pays
inscrits sur la liste noire des paradis
fiscaux de l'union européenne en 2020
les lointaines barbade et anguilles a
situé à 200 kilomètres de bruxelles
luxembourg peut continuer de ronronner
tranquille